they did a little uh parasailing saw
turtles saw sharp is saying when your
kids cool yeah
grows grown man I've done a grown man
who do it to Beijing and your shorts
right up all hai it's all [ __ ] stupid
up there and especially pets you gay
boys on this my shorts are [ __ ] up
our ass details back nuts flop to the
side my brother when you first get like
dams pretty cool then after five minutes
you like we look like doors we've you
feel like an idiot something about
having your your shorts all bunched up
just bunch I don't feel like such an ass
and then you just something like alright
well that wasn't got your another twenty
minutes
that's so funny there's something about
having your shorts punched out it's so
uncomfortable in your back it's just
well yeah everything pushed up in their
harness you know that's kind of like
rock climbing would be the same issue
for me a lot of times I'd be like yes I
have sir
like the first one I'm like that's cool
then after the third fourth link my
daughter was coming down my daughter's
crying the whole time I had to take her
yeah yeah I took my pop babies how about
the guys on zipline how about the guys
are all the hand that they've done of
the cult I'll see you on the other side
oh no man you're a real veteran know hip
line hey whoa man that's not double
triple 15 times Oh dudes they put some
hours on these zip lines huh you want to
waste your life anymore and show off in
front of my family and friends it was
incredible I know is it was interesting
yeah man I'm at home up in these route
and up in these tree tops whoa dude last
time I saw you
yeah I think was last year it was 2000
2017 this profiteering really last year
Brennan did you did you just grab it by
the horns and ride it did you slide in
or you ride it though 2018 gonna be no
idea it's gonna be lit oh man
10:18 is about to be game changers this
is the year that
that I start working up now I do that or
this is no this is thank you what's your
news I really I gear down yeah and I do
stand-up least twice a week you know
this is the year's the year that we
knock out at least two podcasts a week I
do therefore this is the you got to come
up with something give me something this
year your drug habit
I go ops this is the year I'm a little
more kind and I listen more it's
something I've never I've never had some
guy who coughs trap tells girl girls you
don't mind year's resolution was she's
like as read more well well don't set
that goal too high my man you'd [ __ ]
read here if you watch general anyway I
said that next year whether Connor
fights or not they're gonna move on so
they you were saying like you know back
in the days when Chuck Liddell fought if
Chuck Liddell ever left they would they
ever do and if you know Jon Jones Ronda
Rousey feel if what would you do there
they always end up moving on forward he
said they could do the same thing
without Conor McGregor well they have to
that makes its a business you have to
but don't get it twisted don't ever
think that the UFC model it has its
flaws but the UFC train is fueled by
superstars
it is not fueled by the brand because if
it's fueled by the brand which the NBA
the NFL is you're always gonna have
those ratings they say oh they're low
they're still [ __ ] killing it as far
in the grand scheme of things compared
to the UFC but the thing that moves this
UFC engine is superstars it feeds off
superstars the pay-per-view model only
exists if you have superstars so the
mistake that they've made over the past
two years or slash since this old dummy
Emmy is thinking that they did can
survive without these superstars and
they've learned the hard way and this
year shows it so I think when you take
for granted once in a lifetime athletes
like Ronda Rousey Brock Lesnar Conor
McGregor Jon Jones you know these guys
or you take for granted guys like max
Holloway or you take for granted guys
like Jose Aldo or Mighty Mouse or you
know the list goes on and on and we take
for granted these these guys are Amanda
Nunez guys Inc gals
when you take them for granted you don't
build them up and the superstars that it
could be and you go we're just gonna
focus on over here you know and you
think it's about the brand you're gonna
learn very fashion you're gonna end up
with eggs on your face because so he
goes I've gotten burger fights next year
that will be awesome if Connor burger
doesn't fight the UFC is going to go on
they have to I've been hearing this
since you auntie Lee says this I've been
hearing this since you empty what are
you gonna do when shut when Chuck
Liddell's gone times are different now
you know when you say oh where you can
do with Chuck Liddell leaves they're
about eight pay-per-views that year
chuck was in half of them yeah so that's
different because he was everything what
are you doing GSP leaves what are you're
in big trouble in a silver gun list goes
on on Ronda Rousey's last year the was
best in company's history so we're gonna
keep finding new talent put on the best
fights in the world and that we're gonna
continue to do with or without anybody
that's the business minds that you had
what are they gonna do sit there with
their dicks in their hand cuz Conor
McGregor is not fighting you got to move
on but you got us we've got to realize
what you have and you can't just view
them as dispensable superstars they got
their out see you who's next
oh we can create any superstar we want
you can okay we've tried that you've
tried that those superstars are create
them sell out Van Damme
I guess the Cordy car Brian did you see
this says when sparring goes wrong so
they sparred together for they're just
jokingly sparring together and then Van
Damme accidentally kicked him in the
head or the teeth and what's what's Gore
brand do you'll hear I'm talking about
it right now to me it looks super light
so then the Cody's go [ __ ] he
wanted to fight him so Van Damme tried
to apologize he wouldn't accept that
hook kick I was like so mad I looked at
John as they robbed me in my teeth dude
kick me my teeth like playing around
like Cody is not the guy to do that to
men yeah what the [ __ ]
how funny have been if you just Merc
John Club that damn right this guy who
he's up there a 35-pound he was at Club
works big guy 35 and he's like walks
around 165 and he was sparring with
people and and they asked me if I wanted
to get in the ring with him and I go now
I'm okay I'm not gonna get in the ring
with that guy he's fighting right now
and just not gonna do it and he said to
me cuz I guess a guy got in there and
was an amateur and he [ __ ] hit him
and he goes I'll go as hard as you go
but they're due to get in there with a
guy like that who fights professionally
and they up it and they start really
swinging for the fences and don't forget
that the guy's a [ __ ] fighter if you
hit him in the face
something's gonna trigger and he's gonna
come back at you so if you want to play
that game okay
yeah you know guy rank goes I was like
I'm gonna rip his head off
let's drunk laughs and and where he's
supposed to Wow
Van Dam is crying too he said it was
actually on his knees crying and he says
my champion Garba and Carver did know
how to react
would he do well for sure get up Frank
Dux man that's a bummer hilarious though
I mean it just looks like a hook kick
still you can't kick him in no I just
now I know how to fight Cody